this is not okay I better put the three
cards back on top and is your pocket
still empty you were DeYoung it put all
of them into your pocket and keep your
hand on it put them inside and keep your
hand right on top well that doesn't help
Marie can you name a number up to ten
remember we started at ten name a number
up to ten I want to take my lucky number
five okay and can you name a small
number for me too
- so five and - we had thirteen cards
I'm gonna add five for you one two three
four five cards there and you said thing
more I'll bet you it yeah one two so
seven cards total just flew through the
air and landed in your pocket brother
went not yet but when you pull the cards
out you'll notice the pile is
significantly bigger go ahead pull him
out see does it feel bigger yes give
there's no there's no longer thirteen
cards there's not thirteen plus your
five this is twenty cards
yeah count one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
seventeen eighteen nineteen
I want to be involved you asked me how
magic and adorned how they work together
yeah so to me magic is like a logic
puzzle so basically and andorrans is a
logic puzzle so and I think everything
is so it's like when I see a trick that
I don't understand how it works and I
can't find any research on it which a
lot of magicians and you know from a
century go guard their secrets you can
only work backwards so you start to say
well what are the different
possibilities of how to do it you work
on every single method until something
starts to work and then it takes years
to figure out how to actually make it
work so I saw a magician once do this
thing where he puts a it's called needle
through arm and it looks like it really
goes through the arm but then when you
study the needle you know that it could
be rubber something sticking your or so
it looks like it's going through or it
retracts into the handle you know what I
mean like the fake knife thing on
Halloween but now everybody yeah it
looks like it goes in so I figured out a
way to do a very convincing believable
version of that hey so I brought with me
today I brought in this ice pick yeah
now the reason I cut the handle off this
ice pick is because I don't want people
to think oh this thing is retracting and
you know what I mean
marine yeah okay well you will you mmm
and feel make sure it's feel the tip and
make sure it's a it's pretty yeah so it
feels like a good ice pick and feel make
sure the tip is oh yeah are you okay yes
that's very that's pretty sharp this is
this is this is sharp and this is what
it looked like yes now if I was to
really do this and you have to make this
look as believable as possible I would
use alcohol because if just was gonna go
into the flesh you would have to
disinfect it obviously so I brought an
alcohol pad technically it doesn't
really help there's so many different
back there you know things that you
don't want but
it wouldn't look like that Oh see when I
put it here right it looks I mean it
actually looks like it's going into the
hand Maria yeah I get really believably
looks like it's going in see that but it
is well you don't know if the bleed is
attracting or what it's doing you know
the worst part is if you turn your hand
over later and it's gonna go be through
well then no oh you're saying that's
what I need to do to be convincing
interesting the way that you can
actually tells it if it was going in it
would balance right so look but it would
look like it's just balancing they're
not it that is quite yeah I mean brutal
but maybe I worked on this really
serious balancing act I'm just bouncing
you know no no but then here so if we do
this way but Maria see but if it really
was going through you said it would be
the other side yeah so meaning could you
just put your hand right here I have the
nice guys put your hand right here here
yeah good see if you put see how the
hand looks like it's starting to go up
yeah good see good push yeah see how it
looks like it's actually come here yeah
see that see how it looks
what's it but this is this it really
look but it doesn't make sense cuz
there's no blood and it doesn't a part
either
well you know I can help you here just
push give it a push nope yeah you're
just doing it right see how good yeah
but go ahead push push strong again see
how it really looks coming right through
there
see though it's just this is probably
the worst thing ever done yeah see how
it really oh yeah I see button for me
yeah but it doesn't make sense
technically because there's no blood
like if this was really going through
that you know if you scratch your skin
like here there's blood so it doesn't
make any sense
so what what Wilfred reminder yeah
can you grab you want to grab that
yes this is uh well yeah you have a
problem
what up hold it up here good slowly hold
so slow see how it looks like oh good no
pulling I'm pulling it out the very
house this is up I mean look yeah well
oh oh oh oh
mud nothing nothing see nothing
and this is a little present for you to
keep don't use it on any other guests
this is just for you
and put you over for for sharing this
VI yes
yeah Steve okay Adam if you're mayor
salman rushdie or Tyra Banks is to do
this esta yeah what what what you're
doing and we saw from the clip air it do
you call it magic or do you call it
being an illusion so what
how would you explain it I try I can why
not well as a kid